En este vídeo vamos a aprender cómo racionalizar el denominador...
racionalizar...
racionalizar el denominador,
y lo que quiere decir esto es,
supongamos que tenemos una fracción,
cuyo denominador no es un número racional,
la más simple en la que puedo pensar es 1 sobre raíz de 2,
entonces para racionalizar este denominador,
tenemos que representar este número,
de alguna manera,
que no contenga un número irracional,
en el denominador,
y lo primero que podrías cuestionar es, Sal,
¿por qué necesitamos hacer eso?
¿por qué debemos racionalizar denominadores?
y no es que tengas que racionalizarlos,
pero yo pienso que la razón por la cual
en muchas clases de álgebra,
muchos maestros quieren hacer eso,
es para transformar los números en un formato común,
también podemos considerar como me han dicho,
en las remotas épocas en que no había calculadora,
para ciertas operaciones
la gente encontraba más fácil hacerlas
si había un número racional en el denominador,
yo no sé si eso es verdad o no,
quizá también la otras razones por estética,
o alguien podría decir,
no tengo ni idea de lo que es 1 sobre raíz de 2,
no tengo ni idea de qué tan grande es esa magnitud,
prefiero un número racional en el denominador.
Habiendo dicho eso,
aprendamos cómo racionalizar denominadores.
La manera más simple hacerlo es, si el denominador consiste en un simple irracional como éste
tan solo multiplicas el numerador y el denominador,
por el número irracional,
dividido sobre el mismo número irracional,
ahora esto claramente es 1.
Recordemos que cualquier número
dividido sobre sí mismo,
siempre es 1,
por lo que no estamos modificando el número
simplemente estamos cambiando
la manera de representarlo,
y esto ¿a qué es igual?
el numerador es 1 por raíz de 2
lo cual es igual a raíz de 2
y el denominador es,
raíz de 2 por raíz de 2,
bueno, raíz de 2 por raíz de 2
esto es igual a 2,
por definición
este número elevado al cuadrado,
es igual a 2
y lo estamos elevando al cuadrado,
lo estamos multiplicando por sí mismo,
por lo cual es igual a 2.
Hemos racionalizado el denominador,
quitamos la raíz del denominador
pero le hemos llevado al numerador,
Ahora el denominador es un número racional...
un numero racional...
y ahora puedes decir, oye,
ya tengo un número
que es raíz de dos medios,
un número mucho más fácil de nombrar,
lo cual quizás es otra buena razón para
racionalizar el denominador.
Hagamos algunos ejemplos más.
Digamos que tenemos.
7 sobre raíz cuadrada de 15,
lo primero que voy a hacer voy a tratar de simplificar
raíz cuadrada de 15...
15 es 5 por 3,
ninguno de ellos es cuadrado perfecto entonces,
creo que ya tenemos,
esto reducido a su mínima expresión.
Y así como hicimos aquí,
vamos a multiplicar esta expresión por
raíz de 15 sobre raíz de 15,
Esto es igual a, 7 por raíz de 15 es,
7 raíz de 15,
simplemente multiplicamos los numeradores,
dividido entre raíz de 15 por raíz de 15...
raíz de 15 por raíz de 15
es 15,
de nueva cuenta
hemos racionalizado el denominador,
esto es ahora un número racional,
básicamente pasamos el radical al numerador,
el cual es ahora un número irracional,
no hemos cambiado el número,
simplemente cambiamos la manera de representarlo.
Subamos un poco de nivel,
¿qué pasa si tenemos algo ligeramente más complejo? por ejemplo,
12 sobre
2 menos raíz de 5,
en este caso lo que tenemos es un binomio en el denominador.
este binomio contiene un número racional
aquí no puede usar el mismo truco,
si multiplico esto,
por raíz de 5 entre raíz de 5,
aún voy a obtener un número irracional
en el denominador,
deja demostrártelo para que veas que no funciona.
Multiplicamos por raíz de 5 entre raíz de 5 y
¿qué obtenemos?
En el numerador es 12 por raíz de 5,
mientras que en el denominador es... voy a distribuir esto es, 2 por raíz de 5,
menos raíz de 5 por raíz de 5,
es igual a 5.
Como puedes ver en este caso esto no funcionó,
sigue presente la raíz de 5,
aunque esta parte se hizo racional, se hizo 5,
esta parte se hizo irracional,
2 raíz de 5,
así que esto no nos sirve de nada,
cuando tienes el denominador un binomio
que contiene un número irracional.
Lo que usamos aquí es el conocimiento y la habilidad para manejar una diferencia de cuadrados
hagamos una pequeña nota por aquí,
lo que aprendimos hace tiempo
y quizás no hace tanto tiempo, es que,
2 menos raíz de 5,
multiplicado por 2 más raíz de 5,
¿esto qué nos da?
quizás lo recuerdes, pero si no puedes reconocer el mismo patrón en el caso del producto de
"a"
menos "b" por "a" más "b"...
"a" menos "b" por "a" más "b"...
y esto es igual,
como vimos en vídeos anteriores,
a "a" cuadrada menos "b" cuadrada,
a ver rechequemos,
"a" por "a" es igual "a" cuadrada
"a" por "b" es igual a "ab"
"-b" por "a" es igual a menos "ab"
y finalmente "-b" por "b" es igual a "-b" cuadrada.
Estos dos términos se cancelan
y obtenemos finalmente
"a" cuadrada menos "b" cuadrada
entonces aquí tenemos,
2 menos raíz de 5 por 2 más raíz de 5,
lo cual es igual,
"a" el cuadrado de 2 que es igual a 4...
déjame reescribirlo mejor de esta manera...
va a ser igual a 2 al cuadrado, menos
el cuadro de raíz de 5, que es simplemente 5,
así que esto es igual a 4 menos 5 ó -1.
Hemos aprovechado lo que conocemos del producto
de un binomio por su conjugado,
o de factorizar la diferencia de cuadrados,
de cualquier manera, que lo quieras ver
este es el método que vamos a utilizar.
Para racionalizar este denominador,
hagamos eso,
déjame reescribir el problema,
esto es 12 entre 2 menos raíz de 5
y lo vamos a multiplicar por
más raíz de 5
entre 2
más raíz de 5.
De nueva cuenta estamos multiplicando el número, por 1
por lo cual no le estamos alterando,
simplemente estamos cambiando
la manera de representarlo,
y esto va a ser igual a 12 por 2 es 24, más,
12 por raíz de 5,
es 12 raíz de 5,
ese es el numerador
sobre...
y por acá que tenemos...
bueno, de nueva cuenta,
estos son los factores de una diferencia de cuadrados.
Así que esto va a ser,
el cuadrado del primero que es igual a 4,
aquí lo vimos,
va a ser igual a 4 menos 1,
perdón esto es 4 menos 5.
Es aquí tenemos 2 al cuadrado
menos raíz de 5 al cuadrado,
es 4 menos 5,
esto es menos 1
ó podemos escribir 1 en el denominador
y ponemos el signo menos antes de la fracción.
No es necesario escribir el 1 en el denominador,
así es que esto es igual a -24
menos
12 raíz de 5
y de hecho, no tan solo racionalizamos,
sino que también simplificamos bastante la expresión,
se ve mucho mejor,
no sé si lo mencioné al principio,
pero esto es bueno porque esto no es, tan obvio,
si tú y yo vamos a hacer un cohete
y supongamos que esta es tu respuesta
y estar de acá es mi respuesta,
bueno,
no es obvio a simple vista que ambas son iguales,
pero si nos ponemos de acuerdo en siempre racionalizar nuestro denominadores,
¡fabuloso!
vamos a obtener siempre el mismo número,
estamos listos para mandar nuestro cohete a Marte.
Hagamos otro como estos.
Vamos a hacer otro como estos acá abajo...
y vamos ahora,
a hacer uno que incluya variables,
similar a estos pero que incluya variables.
Supongamos que tenemos 5 "y"
sobre
2 raíz de "y"
menos
5.
Vamos a seguir
exactamente el mismo proceso,
tenemos un denominador
que tiene un binomio irracional,
bueno, podría ser un racional
no sabemos realmente cuál es el valor de "y"
ya que "y" puede tener cualquier valor,
en algunos casos será irracional,
lo que si no queremos,
es un radical en el denominador,
entonces esto a
¿qué va a ser igual?
multipliquémoslo por 2
raíz cuadrada de "y",
más 5 sobre 2 raíz cuadrada de "y",
más 5,
y este número
insistimos es simplemente 1,
no estamos modificando el número
simplemente lo estamos multiplicando por 1
y esto ¿a qué va a ser igual?
Empecemos con el denominador,
el denominador va a ser igual a esto,
al cuadrado,
de nueva cuenta,
una diferencia de cuadrados,
va a ser igual a 2 la raíz cuadrada de "y"
elevado al cuadrado menos 5 al cuadrado,
si tu factorizas esto,
lo que se obtiene es 2 raíz cuadrada de "y" más 5,
por 2 raíz cuadrada de "y" menos 5.
Es una diferencia de cuadrados
y el numerador va a ser "5y"
por 2 raíz cuadrada de "y"
o simplemente sería 10
y ésta es "y" a la un medio
y ésta es "y" a la primera potencia.
Podemos escribirlo como "y" raíz de "y"
es decir,
"10y" por la raíz cuadrada de "y",
lo cual también podría escribir
como "y" la tres medios,
o "y" a la un entero un medio,
como la veas mejor,
para finalmente obtener,
"5y" por 5 más "25y",
Y esto lo puedo simplificar aún más.
Nuestro dominador va a ser igual a,
esto es 2 elevado al cuadrado lo cual es 4,
la raíz cuadrada de "y"
elevado al cuadrado es "y"
esto es "4y",
menos
5 al cuadrado menos 25,
y ahora, para el numerador que tenemos aquí
¿qué podemos hacer con él?
podemos escribirlo exactamente
como lo tenemos aquí,
o podríamos factorizar "y"...
hay varias cosas que podemos hacer,
pero mantengamos las cosas simples,
escribámoslo como está,
esto es 10,
déjame escribirlo diferente...
puedes escribir esto como,
10 por "y" a la primera
y ésta es "y" a la un medio,
esto lo puedes escribir como "y" a la 3 medios,
o también lo puede escribir como "y" a la un entero,
un medio, si así lo quisiera,
o podemos dejarlo como está
"10y" raíz cuadrada de "y",
todas estas son equivalentes más "25y",
en fin,
espero que hayas encontrado
la racionalización denominadores interesante.